whatever
more than 5 000 athletes are taking part
in the special olympics this week which
wrap up in orlando florida tomorrow
one of the most impressive achievements
has been underway off the courts and
playing fields it is a massive volunteer
effort to get participants and their
families
to and from the games
correspondent chris van cleave has the
story
with the choreography of a ballet 128
private planes touched down minutes
apart
it's the world's largest peacetime
airlift bringing more than 800 athletes
to and from this year's special olympics
in orlando it felt like we were
celebrities just coming off that plane
just
everybody just rooting for us we flew
with the texas men's basketball team on
a luxurious cessna citation what do you
think
i'm loving it every every moment every
minute
just take off had a little tingle it
tickled but i was good why do this
airlift for our athletes to get to be
treated like the rock stars they are and
it starts with this kind of experience
isn't once in a lifetime for athletes so
when you're a person with intellectual
disability you are stigmatized you are
often invisible they're going to be able
to go back home and say to people
without intellectual disability in their
communities
guess what i did the airlift took two
years of careful planning the biggest
single cost for these olympic teams is
their travel costs so this is one way to
help them get to the games in style
offset those costs for them we'll see
you in orlando pilots like ray bailey
donate their time aircraft and the fuel
this is an expensive donation you're
making a big jet
jet fuel's probably never been more
expensive why do it
this is such a big deal for these to
these kids this is a once in a lifetime
for some of them and to be a part of
that is just really a pleasure it's a
pretty cool way to start this adventure
isn't it yes it's very awesome do you
think this is a memory you'll uh you'll
hold on to i'll hold on to this until
the day i die
an unforgettable flight fit for a
champion
for cbs saturday morning i'm chris van
cleave in orlando
[Music]
job well done